Sex isn't seen
as a dirty word,
it's something
that we all enjoy.
Oh no!
I don't know what I'm doing.
She's the kind of person
that'd dream about someone
and then
makes out with them.
-Yeah.
-I don't do that.
Hello and welcome
to Sex Education Unpacked,
your one-stop shop
for all things
Sex Education, season 3.
I'm your host,
Gena-Mour Barrett.
That's right,
the show that brought you
Otis Milburn's sex clinic,
Lily's weird and wonderful
alien fantasies
and Aimee's
very questionable baking
is back.
This season,
Eric, Maeve, Adam, and co
are going to be tackling
more important topics
than ever
all while facing
some pretty big changes
at Moordale.
In this episode,
we'll be talking about
one of season 3's
most important themes,
gender, sexuality,
and why it's so important
to see yourself represented
on screen.
Joining me today
are Trish Allison,
who plays
Sex Ed's Ola Nyman,
dialling in from the States
is Dua Saleh,
AKA one of Moordale's
newest students, Cal,
plus activist, model,
and founder
of Goddess Platform,
Munroe Bergdorf,
and one of season 3's
very own writers,
Temi Wilkey.
Joining me on the sofa
to kick off the show
are Trish Allison
and Munroe Bergdorf.
Hello!
-Hi.
-Hello.
This season,
we see the blossoming union
between Ola and Lily
as they work
on their relationship
through a time
of change, growth,
and a bit of UFO spotting.
Let's take a look at
one of their magical moments
from season 3.
Hi.
How'd you know I was here?
I didn't.
It's The Eighth tonight.
This is where
it's supposed to happen.
Why are you laughing?
I thought
that this was a bit random.
Oh. Yeah.
Why are you here?
This is my mum's
favourite place.
I'm sorry. I…
I didn't realize how much
you were missing your mum.
I think
we've both been distracted.
I'm sorry I said
that aliens weren't real.
I want to try
and be more open-minded.
It's beautiful here.
Do you really
love this view?
I wish I could tell her
about you.
I know she'd love you.
So, Monroe, we've seen a ton
of heteronormative
representations
of relationships on screen
in the past.
Why is it so important
that we diversify that?
Well, the benefit
of representation
is that it's easier
to understand yourself
when you can see
reflections of yourself.
Especially
when I was growing up,
it's harder to be
what you cannot see.
So, if I had seen a show
like Sex Education
when I was a teenager,
it would have taken away
so much shame
I was experiencing
at that time.
So, representation
is important
because it allows us
to safely discover ourselves
and explore our identity
and not even identify
cut and dry
who we are in that moment,
but go on a journey
with ourselves.
I think
that's a beautiful thing
about being a young person
is there's
a world of possibility
of who you could be
and it's about
exploring that.
Think it's a really
beautiful thing.
Trish, you said before
that Ola isn't somebody
that can be put into a box.
What's it been like
filming with Tanya
over the past few years
and getting to see
both of your characters
develop individually
and as a partnership?
Yeah,
it's been really special
because I've always enjoyed
working with Tanya.
We used sex as a way
to discover our characters,
vaginismus is a huge thing
for Lily's character.
She doesn't
want to be touched
by anybody else,
but she wants to make love
with Ola.
And so,
that was such a good insight
as to who
our characters were.
They're understanding,
they want to, as you say,
go on a journey
with each other.
It's not even
about the end game
because they start
with mutual masturbation
and then in season 3,
we kind of find them
in a different place
that also shows us
that sex is about trust
and getting
to know each other
and feeling like you can be
your most comfortable self
with whoever
you're having sex with
or experiencing that with.
Munroe,
you've previously said
that Gen Z
take a more fluid approach
to gender and sexuality.
What did you mean by that
and how can we keep moving
that conversation forward?
So, the way in which
Gen Z are identifying
and seeing,
not only themselves,
but each other,
is dramatically different
to say millennials,
who are my generation,
and baby boomers,
who are
my parents' generation.
So, baby boomers, typically,
are 88% more likely
to identify as heterosexual,
exclusively heterosexual,
Gen Z are 66% likely
to identify
as exclusively heterosexual,
which is
the lowest percentage
in recorded history.
So we can see
that as time's going on
and there's more information
out there
about different identities
and sexuality
and sex in general,
the way we talk
about sex now is much freer.
There's less shame,
there's a stigma,
and sex
isn't seen as a dirty word,
it's something
that we all enjoy.
And with shows
like Sex Education as well,
I mean,
that's a point of reference
for young people as well
to know that these things
you feel embarrassed by,
you shouldn't feel
embarrassed
because we're all
experiencing them
and they've existed
throughout all of time.
So, the way in which
Gen Z are identifying now
is much more fluid
with regards to,
not just gender identity,
but gender expression.
So, the way in which
they're buying clothes,
the way in which
their interests are forming,
the binary is becoming
much less of a thing.
And the area in between
is being accessed
and identified with
a lot more.
Trish, growing up,
do you wish shows like
Sex Education had existed
when you were in school?
100%. I mean, it's even like
that still weird thing
where I was experiencing
mass amounts of sexism
when I was 16 to 18, still.
The boys in my year
had grown up with that,
-you know?
-Yeah.
I had an incident once
where I was at drama school
and I got up
and I did a monologue.
Then at the end,
one boy was like,
"Oh, next time
you should wear a bra."
-And I was like, "Awesome."
-Oh wow.
Like, that's great that--
Is that what
you took away from that?
That's what I'm saying.
That's micro aggression
and that's shame.
And we just didn't know
how to call it out.
And then you internalize it
and you think
it's your problem,
-your fault.
-Exactly.
And it's just not.
It doesn't even make sense
what we're
carrying around with us.
This show debunked
so many stupid things
that people have done,
like traditional ways
of thinking
or even just
silly facts about sex
and your body
and how you can communicate
with another person.
I believe
teenagers shouldn't have sex
because sex
will ruin your life forever.
I went from having dreams,
to having
a six months old baby
that left me
with a leaky bladder
and a baggy vagina.
It's amazing
from a queer perspective,
to see queer kids
in an educational
environment.
It debunks the myth
that being gay
or being queer
is an adult thing.
I've always been queer.
I was queer in school.
I had those feelings,
those feelings weren't new.
When other kids
that were straight
or heterosexual
were thinking about sex,
I was thinking
about sex as well.
Monroe, how big of a part
do shows like this
play in helping young people
within the LGBT community
to find acceptance
in themselves?
I know
you touched on it before.
Yeah. Again, it's being able
to see yourselves,
but shame
is just the killer of joy
and it's the killer
of empowerment.
And, I mean, I grew up,
and I went
to an all-boys school,
which was
a nightmare, obviously,
but it was a very,
very masculine environment.
And I was experiencing
homophobia and racism.
I didn't understand
how racism functioned
or how homophobia
really functioned.
And it was in a time
when teachers
weren't allowed
to talk about it
because of legislation
called Section 28.
So, I was stuck
and if I had seen
a character like Eric
talking about
what he was experiencing
or his identity,
I think that it would've
made it easier for me
to access
some form of pride.
I think
that the opposite of,
well, the opposite of pride
is shame
And to know
that you're not alone,
what you're going through
isn't an isolated event,
and the opposite
of isolation is community.
And there's other people
out there
that can help you
process it.
Eventually,
you'll meet other people
that have been through
the same thing,
and you'll be able
to laugh about it one day.
But in those moments
when you're experiencing it
it's far
from the funniest thing
-that you can experience.
-Yeah.
I'm in awe
of the both of you,
Trish and Monroe,
thank you so much.
That was such a lovely
and enriching conversation.
-And to meet you properly.
-Thank you.
Monroe,
thanks for staying with me
in the Sex Ed Unpacked
living room.
and joining us
is Sex Ed writer,
Temi Wilkey.
-Hello, Temi.
-Hi.
One of the key storylines
you worked on this season
is Eric's journey
back to Nigeria,
which sees him grow
through the exploration
of his identity
as Black and gay.
How do you feel?
Like I've come home.
When I saw that scene,
I was like,
I've been in lockdown
for too long.
Get me to the club ASAP.
I was like, the dancing,
I need to be there.
So, Temi,
tell us about the process
of writing that storyline.
What did you want the viewer
to take away
from Eric's journey?
The thing I felt
was really important
is that queer people
are in Nigeria.
That was something
that felt like
a second home coming.
It's like one thing
being in Nigeria
and experiencing
a part of your culture
you don't get
to be with every day.
But I think also the fact
that queer Africans exist,
and even though
it's not legal
in lots
of African countries,
they're there
and they're having to hide
and be
in underground communities,
it felt like
another jigsaw puzzle
in Eric's journey
and his experience
of himself.
Yeah.
You've previously spoken
about how important it is
for you personally
to feel seen
and represented.
Is that something
that you wanted to give back
to Sex Ed fans?
Yeah.
I think it already does
so much of that in the show.
It's such an amazing thing
to be a part of
'cause when
I watched the first series
I felt so seen
and represented.
And it's just
taking that even further
as far as you can
push it, really.
There's so many
different intersections
a person can have.
Like being queer
and specifically African
or being queer and Caribbean
or queer and Indian.
There are so many ways
you can push that further
and feel even more seen
and even more represented.
Yeah.
As we saw in the clip,
during episode 6,
Eric talks about feeling
like he's come home
and the freedom
that comes with
accepting his own identity,
is that something
either of you can relate to?
Absolutely.
Finding your people
is such an integral moment
for everyone,
regardless of whether or not
you're queer,
just finding friends
that you feel seen and heard
and relinquishing your shame
or going on that journey
to feeling unashamed
and unapologetically
authentically who you are
is a journey to empowerment.
I think there's something
really special
about being in a queer space
that is also Black.
Like there's something
that's so deep
and liberating
and joyful and full
that takes it
to another level.
I felt like
I had a degree of that
when I was in a queer space
that was
predominantly white.
I was like, wow.
I found my people.
But it goes further
when you find
a queer Black space as well.
Come on, England! Welcome.
Hi! Oh my gosh!
You look incredible.
Hi! How are you guys?
Doing okay?
Thank you.
Monroe,
do you think as people
we're always
going to be evolving
and discovering new parts
of what makes us us?
I think life would be
very boring if we don't.
I think the beautiful thing
about life
is not only
understanding yourself,
but understanding
each other.
I think
once you go on a journey
with picking apart
your own world view,
you can be a better ally
to other communities.
And, for instance,
I don't navigate the world
as a disabled person,
so I don't understand
first hand
what disabled people
go through.
Over recent months,
I've been much more diligent
to educate myself
for people that are
so that I can
extend my platform
and then challenge
other people
to go on
that journey as well.
So, I think
that we've only just begun.
Yeah.
I love that we're existing
in this time
where we're speaking
about lived experiences
and we're adding value
to the voices
of under marginalised people
in a way that we haven't
for so long or ever.
-Yeah.
-So, yeah.
Monroe, always a pleasure.
Temi, thank you so much.
And this episode
is one of my favourites
of all the seasons,
so I really appreciate
you spending time with us.
Thank you both so much
Next up.
We're going to be hearing
from Dua Saleh
who joined season 3 as Cal.
My name is Dua Saleh
and I play Cal
on series 3
of Sex Education.
We're about to watch a clip
of Cal and Hope
struggling with each other
in a conversation about
gender neutral bathrooms.
Hope!
I was wondering if I can
talk to you about
getting a gender neutral
changing room on campus.
I think it'd really help
the trans
and queer students here.
Cal, we can talk
about whatever you like
once you come to school
wearing the correct uniform.
How exactly
would you define correct?
Layla,
could you come here please?
Layla is a perfect example
of how you can express
your identity
and still abide
by school rules.
So, Layla's a good NB
and I'm a bad one.
Is that right?
I don't understand
your slang.
N-B, like non-binary person.
Playing Cal
was a lot of fun.
They're very different
from me as a person
just in them being a skater
and the way
that they're really bold
and upfront all the time.
I sometimes
can be anxious and timid.
So, it really pushed me
out of my comfort zone,
creatively,
and pushed me outside
of my own mental map
and mindscape.
So yeah, it was really fun.
One thing that me and Cal
have in common
is that we both
have a complex understanding
of different
power structures.
I think that's something
that's remarkable
and something
a lot of non-binary people
have to have a knowledge of
because that's how
we're able to survive
in the world
and navigate the world
in a way
that's safest for us.
One of my favourite scenes
to film was the bus scene.
Oh my God!
It was
a really amazing scene
and I loved
everybody's responses
and reactions
to the different things
that were happening.
Especially
with the flying poop.
I'm going to leave you now
with Cal
falling through the vents
and flipping off
the head mistress
of Moordale.
Fuck!
Hey, Hope.
So Monroe,
when looking
at that conversation
that we saw
between Cal and Hope
and about the uniform,
for example,
would you say that
that's a typical example
of how some people
might react to someone
expressing their feelings
about their gender
and what can we do
to change that?
I think
there seems to be a pattern
of people prioritizing rules
and traditions
and guidelines
and especially
within institutions
and not necessarily
embracing change.
So, I think when an instance
like somebody like Cal
is saying,
"I don't feel comfortable.",
that should be listened to
rather than prioritizing
a set of rules or standards
above that.
I think it's really,
really important
that we understand
that when a space
isn't inclusive,
especially
a place of education,
that has a knock-on effect
on that student's ability
to be present,
to fully benefit
from their education.
And then, that will put them
into themselves,
which will then make it
harder for them
to form meaningful
and truthful friendships,
you know?
It's going to be
hard for them to open up.
So, I think
that we should understand
that non-binary
is not just an identity,
it's a person.
And, the sooner
that we understand that
the more
we can embrace change,
whether or not
that's uniform or toilets
or just making spaces safe
for everybody
to feel included.
What would you say
to a young person
who might be struggling
to know how to speak
to their friends and family
about their identity?
I would say take your time
to understand yourself
and open up
when you feel safe
and supported.
It's a process.
When I first came out
to my parents,
it was not great.
We've been
on a journey together
in understanding each other.
There's a quote
from another show
that says when somebody
in a family transitions
the whole family
transitions.
And I think that that's true
for your friends as well.
There's a point
of a climatization, I feel,
of everybody
getting onto the same page.
So, it's really,
really difficult.
And I think
it's really important
that you have friends
that see you and hear you.
So, it's not always easy
but it is worthwhile.
And it's really important
that you do share
how you're feeling.
Eric wasn't my friend, Mum.
He was my...
boyfriend.
We broke up.
Something touched on
in Cal's story
is their desire
to wear a uniform
they feel comfortable in,
not one that's assigned
to their perceived gender.
Can clothing
be an important way
to express how we feel
on the inside
on the outside?
Clothing is a really,
really important thing
for trans people,
especially
when you're younger
and access to things like
hormone replacement therapy
is really difficult
for trans people.
So clothing
and gender presentation
is an immediate way
you can express yourself
and alleviate feelings
of gender dysphoria.
It's like if you're a woman
being called a man
repeatedly,
you're like, well, no,
I'm not a man.
So I get
that same kind of feeling
if I am presenting
as masculine.
I think
that once we allow people
to be themselves,
they just can be
infinitely more present
within the moment
and benefit again
from their education.
Thank you so much, Munroe,
that was amazing.
Trish, Monroe,
welcome to the games area.
This episode,
we've got a challenge
you might remember
from science class,
back in the day.
We're giving you
three minutes
to create a container
that will protect
a highly delicate egg
when dropped
from a great height
or about six feet,
because that's all,
space that we have.
Before we get started,
who here rates themselves,
who was top of the class
in physics?
-No.
Right, okay.
Chat done. Great.
Okay. So, I'm going to put
three minutes on the clock.
Are you ready?
In three, two, one, go!
-Sorry. What?
-Cheating.
-Okay.
Monroe,
you've gone for the tape.
Oh, and the cotton...
Lovely.
-Don't look.
-Okay.
Don't let
the competition go.
You're doing exactly
the same thing as me.
-This is not great.
-Pampers for the egg.
Nappy for the egg.
What's going on--
A balloon-- Right. Yeah.
Okay. Yep.
Don't know what I'm going
to do with it,
-but...
-You seem very certain.
You do seem really certain.
This is how
I live my life, man.
I'm cert-- ah, no!
Wondered what
you were going for.
I don't know. I was...
...address that at the end.
Okay, okay, okay.
This is not easy
to do with nails.
Ooh.
I feel like you've made
a little cloud for the egg.
-Yeah.
-Very nice.
Let's just hope
that it works.
Just so you know,
I didn't do this at school.
So I'm coming from like a...
No, I've never known
about this, ever.
Okay. Well...
-You've never made a--
-No...
Oh no, I don't know
what I'm doing.
Over a minute have gone.
Just so you know.
You have under two minutes
to protect this egg...
-Okay, okay.
-...with your life.
-No, Trish, hide.
-Stop.
Oh, wait! I kind of get
what you're trying to do.
What am I trying to do?
-What is it?
-Little parachute?
Yes! Exactly!
So that it can fly away.
Wait, I have a renewed faith
in this one.
Thanks.
-Renewed faith.
-...if I can get it sticked.
-Okay.
We are a little bit
over halfway now.
Okay. Monroe, folding...
a little bit of origami,
I think, over the egg.
Which is
an interesting tactic
don't know if it's the time.
I have not, I was not good
at physics, so...
-Let's see how this goes.
-Okay.
I'm very, very intrigued.
Ooh, okay.
Wrapping it in the paper,
like a present.
Very nice.
Less than a minute to go.
We've got a straw here.
I'm just trying to use
all the tools
-that are available to me.
-Okay.
'Cause maybe something will,
why is it here, otherwise,
if we're not
supposed to use it?
Like maybe it's
supposed to be a raft
-or something.
-That's four straws
Trish has got for the egg.
Oh, Monroe in
with the balloon.
Why can I not
blow a balloon up?
No, it's not going to work.
-Just stuff it in there.
-You've got fifteen seconds.
Oh my God, no, no!
You've got ten seconds.
-Wait!
-Nine.
Eight. Seven.
Six. Five. Four.
-Three. Two. One.
-Game on, Trish, game on.
Stop! That's it.
That's it with the eggs.
The eggs better be--
-Not the package.
-Looks cute.
All right. So, Monroe,
tell us
about the inspiration
behind this
protective measure.
So,
I wanted to create a box,
but I forgot how to fold,
create a box.
So I just
created a little pocket.
-Okay.
-And then,
I put the cotton wool buds.
I taped them
all around the egg
and then insulated it
with the balloons
I couldn't blow up.
I just ended up
stuffing it in there
with a bunch
of elastic bands
and hope that it absorbs
the shock of the impact.
Okay.
Actually well thought about,
isn't it?
Trish, I'd love to hear
a little bit about
what you went for.
An artistic approach,
I think.
Actually, no, I do know
physics quite a lot
and I know
that balloons fly,
So, this will do something,
hopefully, when you drop it.
Okay. So, the time has come
to see whether
you will murder this egg
or it will survive
another day.
-Okay.
-Try your egg first.
So six foot
is kind of up here.
-Hey?
-Right. Yup.
Ooh!
It didn't, nothing happened.
That didn't sound like
it was bad.
-...just bounced.
-Let's leave it.
We'll do Trish's one.
From the same height,
please.
-I want a nice clean fight.
-Exactly.
Ooh!
I'm not sure about that one.
-And?
-Okay.
Going to have a look
at these eggs.
The balloons
didn't help at all.
Like, this literally
didn't help.
Not even a single bit.
Let's unbox
Monroe's egg first.
Okay.
So, it is cracked a bit,
but not a lot.
So, we've got a little...
-Okay. Oh...
-Yeah? A little bit bruised.
Okay.
Quite a big crack, actually.
No. It's still probably
more alive than Trish's one.
It only cracked
in one little place.
Yeah, exactly. Trish,
we'll pick up the raft.
This is such an indication
of how bad I am
at everything.
No! No...
Sorry.
-Oh...
-Oh no!
That's really, like...
That egg is dead.
You tried
and at the end of the day,
we're all winners.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're all winners.
All winners. In this case,
Monroe is the winner.
-But we're all winners.
-Well done.
Now, we all know
Sex Education
wouldn't be Sex Education
without the fans,
so this is
the part of the show
where we throw it
over to you
in a segment
we've subtly called
"The Fans Ask.
Welcome back to
the Sex Education Unpacked
living room.
We've buried the egg,
let's get stuck into
those fan questions.
First up, we've got Sil
from the Netherlands.
Hi everyone.
I'm a huge, huge fan,
as you can see.
Anyway,
my question to you is,
are there
any personality traits
from your character
that you also have?
And if so,
which ones are they?
Bye.
We have very,
very similar attributes.
Although, we go about life
quite differently,
I would say.
I take more time, I'd say,
to think about things
and we still have
the same drive, as it were.
You know,
the fire that I have,
but in a more immediate way
with Ola.
She's the kind of person
that'd dream about someone
and then
makes out with them.
-I don't do that, you know.
-No.
And, and she just, yeah,
she kind of is always
very sure of the ground
she's walking on
at that very moment.
That's definitely not
something I think I have.
It must be quite fun to play
a character like that.
That is super spontaneous
or, yeah.
Yeah, it's taught me loads
and also just...
given me loads of confidence
to be that way.
And that's been really nice
to learn something
from my character.
So, let's hear from Nature
in South Africa, next.
One thing I wanted to ask
the cast yesterday,
what were
your first impressions
when you first met?
In the beginning,
I was working
with just Asa for ages,
and Gillian,
and that
was amazingly interesting...
for one of my first TV jobs,
I guess.
And so, I was like, oh wow,
they're amazing actors,
but also very,
very grounded people.
So yeah, I was just
actually overwhelmed
by how lovely they were.
And lastly,
here is Rebecca from Norway.
What has been
your favourite episode
to film so far?
My favourite episodes
are season 1, episode 5,
I cried so much,
and season 2, episode 7
with a bus scene.
Oh.
Oh, I love being a woman.
My favourite episode
to film,
she just mentioned it.
It was like episode 7
where all the girls
spent four days together.
'Cause we had a huge stint
and we were
going to be filming on a bus
and the characters
are talking about
personal
traumatic experiences.
And we spent
a really, really long time
just reading it through,
talking to each other,
sharing stories,
and trying to make it feel
as real as possible.
We didn't want to be like,
"Oh, I went through this."
-Yeah.
-"How about you?"
It's a huge responsibility
to talk about
these kinds of things.
And we get that.
We had lots of support
from Netflix,
who organized that.
They made
a really safe space for us,
so we were really happy.
Was a good time.
-Amazing.
-Special memory.
Trish, thank you
so, so much.
And thank you so much
to the fans.
That's it for this episode.
Thanks to Monroe, Temi,
and Trish for joining me
on Sex Education Unpacked.
Don't forget to let us know
what you think
in the comments.